pour revenir sur le sujet de
l'agriculture et l'énergie pour vous
c'est quoi un modèle agricole dans
lequel il ya une contraction sur
l'énergie ça ressemble à quoi
alors c'est un modèle qui disposera
d'une plus grande difficulté à avoir un
débouché à val important enfin
géographiquement large de ces produits
donc ça veut dire que vous devrez
trouver votre zone de chalandise plus
près avec moins d'étapes de
transformation donc je disais tout à
l'heure le maïs parce c'est un
transformateurs d'aliments qui passe
chez le cochon qui passe lui même dans
une découpe dans un abattoir qui passe
dans une découpe industriels qui passent
chez paou qui passe au supermarché qu'il
faut qu'on reste donc ça ça se
raccourcir à c'est une agriculture qui
sera plus sobre en gros animaux parce
qu'elle sera nécessairement moins
productive parce que ce qui aujourd'hui
permet de rendre les cultures très
productive c'est le fait qu'on ait
explosé le cycle de l'azoté
c'est le fait que vous ameniez des
amendements de synthèse en grande
quantité si vous avez juste les
amendements des animaux qui ont été
faites dans les champs ça suffit pas
c'est une agriculture avec des
exploitations qui sont globalement plus
diversifiée c'est une agriculture dans
laquelle vous récupérez des services
écosystémiques qui avant vous
débarrasser d'une partie des maladies et
des ravageurs c'est à dire les oiseaux
la compétition entre insectes et c'est
donc avec des enfants ou des endroits où
il ya des bestioles qui puisse se mettre
parce que ça vous mangerez avouent
manger une partie des prédateurs
c'est une agriculture dont comme j'étais
tout à l'heure les produits en sorties
vont valoir plus cher nécessairement
voilà donc celle inverse de ce qu'on a
fait depuis que on a mis des
combustibles fossiles dans l'agriculture
c'est à dire plus spécialisés plus
exportatrice plus productives
c'est exactement l'inversé de ça je suis
pas en train de vous dire que ça arrive
en une semaine
par contre je ne crois que marginalement
au fait qu'on va avoir des tracteurs
autonome robotisée qui vont vous bouffez
l'équipement se nourrir avec les limaces
qui bouffe dans les champs et ses
pardons et juste pour finir et c'est une
agriculture qui réintègre de la force de
travail je suis totalement convaincu du
fait que le monde dématérialisé à cause
de ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas des employés de bureau qui
ressorte le soir avec le pli du pantalon
impeccable le grand paradoxe est qu une
économie plus dématérialisé est une
économie dans laquelle il ya plus de
travail manuel donc vous avez parlé de
la contraction énergétique jeudi en
attend
qu'est ce que vous voyez comme solution
vous avez parlé de l'éolienne du
nucléaire comment est-ce que vous alors
j'ai déjà commencé ce matin vous
rappeler qu'elle est déjà là en europe
cette contraction énergétique l'énergie
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui dans le
monde est à 80% constitué de
combustibles fossiles
les combustibles fossiles portent bien
leur nom puisque c'était restes
fossilisés de vie ancienne la manière
dont le pétrole et le gaz se sont
constitués c'est vous avez du planton et
des micros agde qui ont fait des résidus
organiques mélangé à du sédiment
minérale près des côtes en général par
la tectonique des plaques ce truc là est
enfoui sous le sol
et là j'étais un niveau cuissard vous
distille sa petit feu jusqu'au moment où
ça vous exsude du gaz et du pétrole qui
vont dans les bons cas de figure se
concentrer dans des roches poreuses qui
sont situés au dessus il faut 50 à 400
millions d'années pour que ça se passe
donc c'est un peu long pour que ce soit
renouvelable
le charbon c'est les fougères qui ont
poussé à l'ère du charbon au carbonifère
donc il ya quelques centaines de
millions d'années 300 si ma mémoire est
bonne qui se sont fossilisés avec le
même processus et qui donne aujourd'hui
des veines de charbon 80% c'est la
poisse donc de l'approvisionnement
énergétique c'est des combustibles
fossiles
le fait de passer à autre
alors pas dans ces combustibles fossiles
sont épuisables d'accord comme il se
renouvelle en 50 à 400 millions d'années
la vitesse à laquelle on tape dedans
leur permet pas de se reconstituer et là
vous avez un petit théorique de maths
qui vous dit quand vous tapez dans un
stock de départ qui peut pas se
reconstituer
l'extraction de votre stock suis un
piquant de polytechniciens là sa part de
zéro ça passe par un maximum et ça
repart à zéro c'est vrai soit dit en
passant pour le pétrole et le gaz mais
c'est vrai pour le minerai de cuivre et
c'est vrai pour l'argent d'accord tout
ce qu'on peut sortir de la croûte
terrestre qui n'est pas renouvelable
aura un pic à son extraction annuel
nécessité mathématiques il se trouve
qu'en ce qui concerne le pétrole dits
conventionnels
c'est à dire tout ce qui n'est pas le
pétrole de roche-mère le pétrole et le
gaz qui restaient prisonniers dans la
roche mère qui l'a vu naître avant de
migrer vers une roche réservoir et tout
ce qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
c'est à dire ce qu'on a au canada et qui
est du vieux pétrole qui a migré en
surface qui a perdu ses éléments
volatils dans un dans une roche qui
était du sable donc ça vous fait une du
sable mélangé à du bitume
et bien tout ce qui n'est pas les sables
bitumineux et le pétrole de roche-mère
la production mondiale a décliné depuis
2008 qui en avait déjà entendu parler
vous êtes beaucoup bien informé que la
population monde peuvent française et
pourtant toutes les mains de relever
c'est le déclencheur directe de la crise
des subprimes c'est le déclencheur
directe de la crise des subprimes j'ai
pas mes graphiques aujourd'hui pour vous
le montrer mais
j'ai des enregistrements vidéo sur
internet vous irez voir la démonstration
dessus en basse résolution donc bah oui
finances a fait trop de production
numérique donc le le pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde décline
depuis 2008 alors le pétrole non
conventionnel pour le moment il fait
plus que compenser le déclin mais dans
ce non conventionnel on a du mal à
savoir ce qu'il ya exactement parce que
vous avez du vrai pétrole vous avez du
faux pétrole des liquides de gaz etc
donc c'est un peu difficile d'y
retrouver ses petits l'alimentation
européen en pétrole décline depuis 2006
donc de 2006 à 2014 ça décline de 2014 à
2018 c'est reparti dans l'autre sens
c'est la raison pour laquelle hollande a
vu la courbe du chômage s'est inversée
sur la fin de son mandat et macron a vu
la courbe du chômage s'inverser sur
début de son mandat il ni l'un ni
l'autre n'y sont pour quoi que ce soit
c'est juste que l'approvisionnement
européen en pétrole est reparti dans
l'autre sens et c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle les émissions de co2 des
transports sont en partie dans l'autre
sens même cause même de deux effets
différents donc l'europe déclinant
pétrole depuis 2006
et ça va recommencer à s'inverser dans
pas longtemps le l'approvisionnement
européen en gaz décline depuis 2005 à
l'époque en 2005 60 % du gaz européen
vert de la mer du nord qui a passé son
pic en 2005
donc depuis l'approvisionnement européen
en gaz décline l'approvisionnement
européen en charbon décline depuis au
moins 1980 donc bien avant les sujets de
changements climatiques parce que ça
fait deux siècles comptable dans les
mines de charbon en europe et donc le
déclin géologique enfin le début du
déclin géologique est passé depuis
longtemps
1914 je crois en grande bretagne 10 950
je crois en allemagne enfin bon voilà
donc c'est il ya longtemps que c'est
passé charbon pétrole et gaz font aussi
80% de l'approvisionnement énergétique
européen aussi il soit dit en passant
pour l'énergie qui rentre dans les
machines en france les combustibles
fossiles vont les trois quarts
donc vous avez tous lu dans le journal
qu'on était un pays tout nucléaire non
on est un pays à dominante nucléaire
dans l'électricité mais si je regarde
toutes les machines qui fonctionnent en
france trois quart de l'énergie qui les
alimentent parce que dans ces machines
ya aussi des voitures des camions des
trois-quarts de l'énergie qui les
alimentent ces des combustibles fossiles
en france aussi
donc l'approvisionnement européen en
charbon décline l'approvisionnement
européen en gaz décline
l'approvisionnement européen en péril
dans pétrole pardon décline école zéro
plus zéro ça fait toujours la tête à
toto l'approvisionnement énergétique
européen décline donc nous la
contraction énergétique
on y est déjà accor est en fait toute la
zone ocde il ya déjà le japon il ya
aussi la même les états unis ils sont
d'une certaine manière et c'est ça qui
explique le marasme économique dans ces
pays n'arrive pas à sortir malgré les
inondations de milliers de milliards par
la banque centrale
et malgré tout ce qu'on peut mettre
comme petit trou dans le droit social
pour essayer de faire en sorte que les
gens bossent pour moins cher
malgré tout ça le truc continuer le
marasme dans cette affaire-là que
peuvent les sources non fossiles alors
dans les sources non fossiles vous en
avez 2 vous avez les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire
alors en fait je devrais dire les
nucléaire parce que plusieurs manières
d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire n'a pas
qu'une l'une comme l'autre ont quand
même un peu besoin quand même des
énergies fossiles
les énergies renouvelables ont besoin
des énergies fossiles parce qu'il faut
fabriquer le collecteur de l'énergie
renouvelable
il faut fabriquer le barrage 6 et de
l'hydroélectricité fabriquer la
chaudière
si c'est une chaudière à bois et pour
celles qui viennent à l'esprit de tout
le monde aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
eh bien il faut de l'énergie fossile
pour faire la métallurgie et la chimie
qui vont permettre de fabriquer des
panneaux et des éoliennes
et soit dit en passant il faut beaucoup
plus de métallurgie pour faire des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires que
pour faire des modes traditionnels de
production électrique parce que vous
avez 50 fois plus de métal nécessaires
pour produire un kilowattheure éolien ou
solaire que vous n'en avez besoin pour
faire un kilowatt heure avec une
centrale à gaz à charbon ou même
nucléaire dont vous avez des besoins en
métaux qui sont considérablement accrues
et en fait c'est ce qui fait dire à des
gens comme moi que de déployer des
énergies type éoliens ou solaires pour
pallier les énergies fossiles
butera sur une autre limite physique qui
est le besoin en ressources métallique
et du coup ça va se traduire
économiquement par le fait que les
investissements nécessaires sont
absolument faramineux
l'allemagne a déjà vu quelques centaines
de milliards d'euros quelques centaines
de milliards d'euros
dans ces éoliennes et ses panneaux
solaires un ça lui a pas permis de se
débarrasser des centrales préexistantes
qu'elle conserve pour quand il ya pas
assez de soleil ou passer devant
donc elle a gardé les centres afin alors
un peu moins nucléaires un peu plus de
gaz mais en gros elle a gardé les
centrales existantes et elle a rajouté
deux par dessus des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires pour quelques
centaines de milliards d'euros ça que
marginalement aux pc les émissions
allemandes
donc c'est un truc qui va demander des
dizaines de milliers de milliards
d'euros avant qu'on en voit le bout
c'est donc on va pas y arriver avec le
solaire et l'éolien le nucléaire on va
pas y arriver non plus dans les temps
impartis alors déjà c'est une très
mauvaise idée de s'en séparer alors y en
a déjà
donc je fais partie des gens qui pensent
que de s'en séparer en france la
dernière des conneries à faire qu'on a
plusieurs gens beaucoup plus urgents
inférieur
le jeu peut revenir sur les dangers du
nucléaire ça vous intéresse mais j'étais
venu faire une conférence là dessus ici
qui doit être filmé quelques années donc
ressortir les archives et puis l'autre
l'inconvénient majeur du nucléaire c'est
que c'est un système lent c'est à dire
quand le blog entre le moment où vous
donner le top départ et le moment où
vous avez une série de centrales qui est
disponible il faut compter 20 à 30 ans
la construction en version crash
programme un des centrales en france qui
a démarré dans les années 70 elle s'est
terminée en 1990 quelque chose donc
et c'était en version crash programme un
truc qu'on serait plus capable de faire
politiquement aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que quand il ya eu le dialogue entre le
président d'edf à l'époque qui
s'appelait marcel boiteux qui ne l'est
pas du tout question aux cervelles je
peux vous assuré le premier ministre de
l'époque et pierre messmer je me
rappelle enfin boîte bladi dont je me
rappelle très bien
messmer lui dit monsieur le président
combien ce que vous pouvez faire deux
réacteurs par an si vraiment je vous
demande de pousser tous les voulons tous
les tous les feux à fond boiteux
réfléchit lui dis bon aller au maximum
maximorum je peux en faire six et
messmer de lui répondre très bien vous
montrer cette aujourd'hui on n'imagine
pas macron dix ans à lévis vous allez me
faire sept réacteurs
vous allez de démarrer sept réacteurs
par an quoi qu'est ce qui se passe
lafreux produc les airs machin etc en
plus ces dlc pas faire un disque
parfaitement aujourd'hui ils sauront
refaire donc le donc c'est un système
qui est lent
c'est juste c'est sale c'est ça le
problème donc là où il y en a fallu
garder là où on peut le développer faut
évidemment le développer parce que ça
allège la peine sur le reste encore donc
ça fait partie des parachutes devant
trop on va dire c'est beaucoup plus
économe en métal et en espace que les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables là
aussi il faut 1000 fois plus d'espacé
pour faire du solaire que pour faire du
nucléaire la production équivalente
donc vous avez un petit sujet avec le
solaire c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour des
plantes pour déployer les pas d'eau on
est obligé de bouffer sur des surfaces
agricoles et sur des forêts avec ce que
je viens de vous raconter je pense que
ce n'est pas une bonne idée donc le donc
vous avez des besoins importants
les deux seules énergies renouvelables
dans le monde pour finir là-dessus
qu'ils ont qui continue à jouer un rôle
important c'est la biomasse et
l'hydroélectricité et donc c'est des
énergies pour lesquelles vous avez de la
chance vous en avez pas dit autrement si
vous êtes dans un pays dans lesquels il
ya plein de forêt par habitant est plein
de montagne par habitant j'ai nommé la
suède alors là vous pouvez vous pouvez y
pensez donc 9 million d'habitants sur
les deux tiers de la surface française
70 % de forêts et des barrages à gogo
la suède peut rêver d'un monde quasi
industrielle avec des derniers jours des
énergies renouvelables elle peut en
rêver nous c'est pas possible
la belgique encore moins non mais ils
sont un peu plus densément peuplées que
nous et les pays-bas non plus donc le et
l'europe dans son ensemble non plus donc
il faut plus de montagne ou plein de
open forêt pour avoir des énergies
renouvelables c'est une affaire d'
espace essentiellement absolument en
france je vais jusqu'à dire qu'il faut
tout de suite arrêter les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires qu'on n'aurait
jamais dû démarrer les énergies
renouvelables contentons finances il
faut mais on aurait aussi dû ne pas
faire iter parce que la fusion est un
truc que vous serez mort que ça aura
toujours pas démarré à une échelle
industrielle
donc moi vous savez quand alors j'aurais
quand même dû donner l'échelle de temps
pour se limiter aux 2 degrés s'il faut
que je vous dise ans pour se limiter aux
2 degrés de réchauffement est ce que
vous savez par combien il faut diviser
les émissions planétaires d'ici à ce que
vous ayez même pas mon âge
d'ici à 2050 par trois ou par cinq sa
serait mieux c'est plutôt un degré et
demi pas trois donc il faut les diviser
par trois en trente ans alors maintenant
je vais vous donner un autre chiffre
il n'y a pas de futur banquiers j'espère
dans cette salle mais si vous étiez
futur banquiers une division excellent
sait faire ça pour vous quand
l'ordinateur marche une division par
trois en trente ans et moins quatre et
demi pour cent par an il ya deux années
au xxème siècle deux pas trois de ou les
émissions de co2 ont baissé de plus de
4% dans l'année ce que vous pouvez le
deviner
pas 1980 pas du tout non je crois que
j'ai entendu la bonne réponse en proa
pas soixante dix alors 29 ans 145 bien
l'année de l'éradication industrielle de
l'allemagne et du japon
voilà ça ça fait moins 4% dans l'année
l'autre année où on a eu ça c'est le
paroxysme de la crise de 29
en l'occurrence et 1,32 donc il faudrait
faire ça tous les ans à partir de
maintenant tous les ans à partir de
maintenant pour tenir les deux degrés on
fait pas ça tous les ans à partir de
maintenant l'antarctique se désagrège
choisis ton camp camarade comme dirait
l'autre
et oui c'est ça c'est ça le sait ça le
deal donc je comprends la question qui a
été posée tout à l'heure est ce que le
manifeste va etc
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas ça peut
pas faire de mal le voilà donc le dos
est-ce qu'en france dans ce genre de
contexte
avec ce que je crois être le danger du
réchauffement climatique et du sevrage
non non anticipée des énergies fossiles
c'est à dire en gros la guerre partout
est ce que dans cette affaire la
remplacer du nucléaire par des éoliennes
me paraît être le premier endroit où on
doit mettre nos milliards à l'évidence
non à l'évidence non pour vous donner
deux ordres de grandeur est-ce que vous
ça alors là au moment où je vous parle
en fait plus exactement à fin 2010 8 le
contribuable français via l'état s'est
engagé à payer 100 milliards d'un peu
plus de 100 milliards d'euros 120 au
producteur d'électricité éolienne et
solaire pour les contrats qui ont été
conclus avant décembre 2018 donc dit
autrement tous les propriétaires
d'installations qui avant le 31 décembre
2018 avait mis leurs installations avec
contractualiser avec l'état en disant je
vais faire ce truc là où j'ai déjà fait
et je vends mon électricité à tarif
d'achat garanti la somme de tous ces
gens là va encaisser 100 milliards
d'euros d'impôts 120 milliards d'euros
l'impôt
ces impôts viennent historiquement de
taxe sur l'électricité est maintenant de
taxes sur les carburants
donc les gilets jaunes sont très
contents de payer des taxes pour
construire des éoliennes qui vont
vachement les aider à se déplacer pour
moment ils s'en sont pas rendu compte
mais toujours il s'en rendre compte
c'est pas sûr qu'il soit ravi le avec le
tiers de cette somme
je supprime la totalité des chaudières
au fioul dans ce pays la totalité pour
les remplacer par des pompes à chaleur
dans le premier cas de figure je n'ai
pas baissé le co2 puisque le nucléaire
comme les éoliennes ça fait pas de co2
j'ai augmenté le risque nucléaire parce
que je vais garder mes centrale comme
les allemands ont gardé leur centrale
pour assurer la fourniture électrique
quand ya pas de vent je vais garder les
centrales françaises pour la fourniture
électrique quand ya pas de vent
simplement je vais moins m'en servir
dans l'année puisque quand il ya du vent
je m'en servirai pas donc elles vont
gagner moins d'argent que pensez vous
qu'ils aillent vient de l'entretien de
quelque chose qui a des coûts fixes et
gaillarde moins d'argent
je suis pas complètement sûr que ça va
contribuer à améliorer la sûreté
nucléaire
je suis même assez persuadé de l'
inverse donc on va dégrader la sûreté ne
rien faire sur le co2 et détruire de
l'emploi globalement parce que quand
vous faites un mégawatt heure nucléaire
dans ce pays
vous apportez un euro d'uranium quand
vous faites un mégawatt heure solaire
comme c'est pas nous qui fabriquons les
nacelles ni nous qui fabriquons les
panneaux solaires les dix premiers
fabricants de panneaux aujourd'hui sont
chinois et les fabricants d'éoliennes
sont chinois ou sister que même quand
vous achetez une éoliennes vestas ou
siemens
maintenant la nacelle est fait en chine
l'usiné fait en chine donc vous
augmentez les importations donc vous
augmenter le risque nucléaire vous
augmentez les importations et vous ne
gagnez rien en co2 donc comme truc de
shadocks on fait pas mieux quoi donc
évidemment que c'est le premier truc que
j'arrêterai donc je m'occuperai des
chaudières à fuel des chaudières à gaz
de diminuer la taille des voitures et de
convertir tous les agriculteurs à
l'agriculture douce dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure parce que je suis sûr qu'avec
100 milliards je vais quelques petits
trucs dans ce pays donc et ça me paraît
beaucoup plus pertinent que le gouffre à
milliards qui a juste été la sucette
électorale que hollande a vendu au verre
donc il a vendu son droit d'aînesse pour
un plat de lentilles en l'occurrence son
droit d'aînesse c'est l elysée enfin
hertz est le plat de lentilles c'était
je vais taper sur le nucléaire en
construisant des éoliennes mais c'est un
truc quand vous regarder objectivement
c'est un truc qui n'a strictement aucun
intérêt
je suis rien quelque part c'est la
meilleure preuve qu'on n'a pas compris
qu'il y avait un problème urgent il y
avait une main levée là depuis longtemps
il y en a une aussi là-bas et puis je
crois qu'un une là bas aussi qui du coup
vous avez soulevé un problème qui
n'avait pas été soulevée donc j'en
profite vous avez dit qu'il ya un
problème d'approvisionnement et que
c'était un problème clé pourquoi est ce
que le prix arrive pas à réguler à un
problème d'approvisionnement
parce que dans les autre chose alors
vous avez appris un premier truc qui ne
sert à rien en économie qui s'appelle
l'utilité et il sert à rien parce qu'il
n'est confronte à bhl a aucune
expérience
je n'ai pas d'expérience ou en mesure d
utile et bien il ya un deuxième truc que
vous avez pris en économie qui est faux
qui est qu'il y a une élasticité prix
volume qui est persistante
alors en fait il n'ya pas d'élasticité
prix volume persistantes sur l'énergie
il ya une élasticité prix volume
instantané mais l epa persistante dans
les graphiques que je vous ai pas montré
mais vous pouvez le retrouver sur mon
site perso j'ai un article que j'ai
publié dans les haies dans les échos il
ya quelques années que j'ai reproduit
sur mon site perso qui s'appelle le
pétrole est-il élastique en fait je
parle évidemment du prix du pétrole et à
la suite j'ai vidé graphique et un
graphique que j'ai fait dans lequel je
regarde comment varier le prix du
pétrole en fonction de la quantité qu'on
peut acheter dans l'année qui en fait la
quantité produite dans l'année et il n'y
a strictement aucune relation univoque
entre les 2 0 ça ressemble à un pas de
nouilles
ce qui veut dire alors pourquoi c'est
comme ça parce que le pétrole est une
denrée essentielle au fonctionnement de
l'économie
en fait aujourd'hui le pétrole en volume
c'est le premier facteur limitant de
l'économie le premier il y en a pas deux
y en a qu'un c'est celui-là plus de
pétrole plus d'économies moins de
pétrole - d'économie c'est exactement
comme ça que ça marche que la fed fasse
ce qu'elle veut et que macro ont fait ce
qu'il veut sur les charges sociales
c'est juste comme ça que ça marche
le camp vous avez moins de pétrole
instantanément vous allez avoir une
hausse de prix donc la hausse de prix
existent l'élasticité existe à court
terme mais si vous avez moins de pétrole
vous avez donc une économique
peut vous offrir moins de transport donc
l'économie produit - donc le pib des 106
le pib des sens comme le pib c'est la
somme des revenus les revenus de vos
consommateurs descendent donc l'offre de
pétrole est descendue mais les revenus
de vos consommateurs sont descendus
aussi est à ce moment vous avez un
nouveau prix d'équilibré qui n'a aucune
raison d'être au dessus du prix que vous
avez eue au moment du choc
et en fait il est en dessous par
ailleurs comme le pétrole est un facteur
limitant alors quand vous avez un choc
le prix du pétrole monte
du coup les producteurs de pétrole sont
incités à aller en chercher qui était
pas rentable avant donc l'offre va un
peu augmenté
les conservateurs vont faire un peu
gaffe d'abord parce que c'est la
récession et ensuite parce que le prix
du pétrole est monté
donc ils vont en consommer un peu moins
du coup pas longtemps après vous allez
vous retrouver avec une offre un peu en
surplus à ce moment le prix se casse la
gueule
d'autant plus que le pouvoir d'achat de
votre consommateurs avait un peu diminué
à ce moment les producteurs de pétrole
se disent puisque le prix est bas je
vais pas aller en chercher du en plus
parce que c'est pas rentable
donc ils coupent dans leurs
investissements mais comme le prix est
descendu le consommateur se dit quand
même genre consommer un peu plus le cuir
descendu avec et avec le lait fait du
prix élevé précédant l'offre a été
appuyée d'approvisionner donc ils en
consomment un peu plus alors que les
investissements diminuent à ce moment la
production repart à la baisse la demande
repart à la hausse et boum et vous
recommencez de cycle donc en fait vous
allez avoir le prix du pétrole
la seule chose que vous êtes capable de
théoriser sur un approvisionnement
contre un c'est qu'il sera aussi y en
ait en fait ce qui va vous donner la
dureté de la contrainte c'est à mon avis
deux éléments un don je suis sûr
inquiétudes hypothèse mais l'avenir le
dira ce dont je suis sûr c'est que ceux
qui vont au delà contraintes sur la
disponibilité du pétrole c'est non pas
le prix de marché du pétrole c'est la
quantité d'investissement qu'il faut
mettre sur la table pour extraire un
baril jour supplémentaire et il se
trouve que le premier à m'avoir dit ça
aussi simplement c'est l'auteur de des
limites ce gros puisque j'ai eu
l'immense honneur dans ma vie de
rencontrer monsieur dennis meadows et il
m'avait dit exactement ça il m'avait dit
la rareté des ressources naturelles ne
se verra pas à travers leur prix de
marché
elle se verra à travers le fait qu'il
faudra mettre de plus en plus
d'investissements pour extraire une
unité supplémentaire de ressources et
quand vous regardez le pétrole c'est
très exactement ce qui se passe
le pétrole de schiste demande beaucoup
plus d'investissement par baril extrait
les sables bitumineux demande beaucoup
l'offshore profond demande beaucoup plus
d'investissement par baril extrait que
les grands gisements conventionnels à
terre sur lesquels les drones de chez
toi qui sont allés se faire la main et
pas longtemps ou le prix d'extraction
reste ridicule
le puits d'extraction dans ses gisements
ses 5 dollars le baril c'est 0 3 centime
le kilowattheure 0,3 centime le
kilowattheure de pétrole avec la
fonction de stock déjà incluse le prix
du kilowattheure éolien dans les bons
cas de figure c'est 4 à 5 centimes sans
la fonction de stock avec la fonction de
stock vous monte à 15 à 20
donc vous avez un rapport de 1 à 100
quasiment entre le pétrole qui attend
sous nos pieds gentiment ans qu'on
vienne le chercher et l'éolienne qu'il
faut construire en plus avec du pétrole
déjà sans pétrole ça serait encore plus
cher qui nous sort l'énergie du vent
c'est à dire 1 kg par mètre cube
[Musique]
donc le donc le voilà donc sur tout ça
pour dire que le prix n'est pas le
marqueur le marqueur c'est le capex par
unité extraites et le deuxième marqueur
à mon avis ça sera la volatilité du prix
quand on était avant les premiers chocs
pétroliers
c'est à dire avec une offre pléthorique
le prix a été écartée lisez par les
producteurs il resté stable pendant un
siècle quasiment après en dollars
constants il restait stable
ah oui les chocs pétroliers qui est le
début d'un homme d'une modification de
la dérive et sur l'offre de pétrole le
pétrole croissait de 8 à 9% par an il
qu'on ne croit plus que de 1% par an
après un gros changement dérivés à ce
moment là le prix commencent à aussi
alors il aussi avec une grande longueur
d'onde 10 15 ans premier choc en 1974 79
ça redescend deuxième choc dans les
années 90 ça redescend troisième choc
dans les années 2000 ça redescend
ça remonte plus vite 2008 2009 sas
castagnolles 2010 ça remonte jusqu'en
le cas ça se casse la gueule puis la
sarre commencé à remonter puis ça voilà
donc la longueur d'onde va se raccourcir
c'est ça c'est ça mon marqueurs pour moi
mais alors ça c'est une hypothèse que je
pose des gens n'est pas la démonstration
formelle mais j'ai envie de dire que le
truc qui attire ma vigilance à moi qui
capte ma vision c'est de regarder la
longueur d'onde de l'oscillation et plus
elle se raccourcit plus ça veut dire
qu'on commence à avoir une contrainte
sérieuse sur le sur la disponibilité